So I was first introduced to haul about four years ago,
and this is,
I had just moved back to the bay area with my wife and we drove up to Napa and
it was our first time up to Napa.
We had never been,
they're completely clueless as to where to go,
just kind of winging it.
But I think like most novice wine drinkers,
we just knew that we liked reds and we like big reds.
And so we're driving down St Helena and we saw the sign,
was it a crazy,
crazy good calves?
And we're like,
okay,
why not?
So we pulled in and we were blown away,
not just buy the wine by,
by the facility.
Everyone there was so kind and nice to us.
Um,
and uh,
we signed up as members and that was about four years ago and we'd been members
since and that's kind of what turned us on to wine.
Um,
so we,
you know,
we make a trip up to an APP and maybe on a monthly basis these days.
And so it's,
it's actually can add a pretty big impact on our lives.
Um,
so I am a very happy to have you guys here and thank you David for this
opportunity.
Um,
so I'd just like to introduce our guest for today.
so captain hall is a Copra Pirate of hall wines and Walt Wines along with her
husband Craig and therefore children.
Uh,
Catherine has been involved in the California wine industry since her family
first purchased a a winery 30 years ago.
Um,
she has had a distinguished career as a successful business woman,
community activists,
and as the United States ambassador to Austria.
So all this you can read in her book.
Um,
and also joining us today is her daughter Jennifer Brown.
So Jennifer is the halt and hall and Walt's partner,
brand ambassador representing the winery nationally,
uh,
tasting and equitable educational events like the one where we were having
hosting here today.
Um,
she graduated from Northwestern university and received her JD and Mba from
Stanford.
Very impressive.
We are hiring by the way.
Oh No.
Um,
so Catherine at Google,
we pride ourselves on having a very diverse workforce.
We believe diversity contributes to more collaborative environment,
um,
which eventually leads to more innovative products that address the needs of
like broad audiences.
Um,
Catherine,
your background is quite diverse from lawyer to Merrill,
Merrill mayoral candidate,
uh,
to ambassador to Austria.
How have your experiences outside of the wine industry influenced you
in many ways?
Um,
first of all,
Daniel,
thank you so much for having us here,
Jennifer,
and I've been really excited to see you all to see you,
to see you all Googlers.
Thank you for having us and thanks for coming.
Um,
so I totally agree that diversity leads to creativity and uh,
in sort of a depth of experience,
that sort of tapestry that comes forward in,
um,
in so many ways in your life.
So I always,
I was going to come back
to this business.
Uh,
eventually.
I mean,
I love my happiest memories as a kid were watching my dad grow grapes,
farm grapes,
and so I just knew I'd come back.
I just didn't know quite how long it would take.
But in terms of a sort of experiences I'd say as a lawyer,
uh,
you really,
you have to learn.
I mean there's so many experiences from everything,
right?
But yeah,
I think there's a Laurier you learn to speak and therefore to think precisely
and to communicate in that way.
Um,
I think as a candidate for office,
and actually I ran twice and lost twice.
And so,
uh,
the biggest lesson from that I think was dealing with failure,
which I think really speaks a lot to the Google community too.
You know?
I mean I think if you don't,
if you don't take risk,
uh,
and you don't fail,
then you're not going to grow.
I mean nobody wants to fail,
but you do.
I mean that's just the other side of risk and the other side of that too,
its risk,
its failure and its creativity and they all sort of work together.
And so I think that has been a really important part for me.
The other thing is too,
I think is when you,
when you fail and you get up again,
that gives you a confidence that,
that you can't learn.
I don't think any other way to know that you can come back and keep on going.
So I think that all of those factors really come into who we are as a winery.
I mean,
there's many other things and we're so much a team,
but I think our DNA is so much about risk failure,
hopefully not too much of that.
Um,
and uh,
creativity,
just keep on trying.
Beautiful.
Great.
And so,
Jennifer,
I just want for you,
so here
Google
constantly trying to shake the industry up,
um,
in our space and everything that we're involved in,
uh,
you know,
innovate or die,
they say.
So what is hall doing to stay on the cutting edge of technology and innovation
in the wine industry?
Sure.
That's a good question.
First of all,
I think innovate or die is a really intense but awesome.
A slogan.
I like that.
Um,
we're not quite that intense at the way we talk about it.
but we do like to take risks like my mom said.
And I think risk taking leads to creativity and experimentation is a big part of
our winemaking philosophy at the winery are winemakers all designate part of
their time to doing experiments.
Some really cool examples of them,
uh,
are first of all,
our wine maker,
Steve,
we'll back our head winemaker and VP.
He,
uh,
had this idea of toasting the stems of some of our Pino grapes and putting those
in the fermentation tank with the grapes.
And some other wineries put stems in with the grapes and ferment,
but no one else toast them slowly like he did.
And so it gives it a really nice sort of full bodied,
uh,
sense of flavors and like Nice Paprika,
whereas if you don't toast them,
which other a lot of other wineries too,
it's kind of more of a green quality that's can be a little bit risky in the
wine making process.
So,
um,
the fact that he experimented with that and it worked out really well,
we were super excited about that.
And then,
um,
another example of an experiment is,
so we,
we work with the vineyard in the Santa Rita Hills area,
which is by Santa Barbara.
And the wine that we make from there has a really nice perfume quality to it.
And our winemakers had an idea like,
does this perfume quality come from the soil or does it come from the grapes or
something else?
So they actually took the soil from the Santa Rita hills vineyard and threw it
in to an experimentation tank.
Don't worry,
you're not drinking dirt right now into an experimentation with some of our
Pinot grapes.
And it did impart that perfume quality.
So because of that experiment,
they learned the soil had a huge part of that quality of the grapes.
So we just think that these experiments that they're doing are constantly making
us better for our wines.
So that's part of our innovation.
When we think about technology,
we're always trying to get the best new,
most cutting edge technology at the property.
We go around the world and other wineries and talk to Uc Davis,
which has a wonderful winemaking program and learn about what the greatest new
technologies are.
We have,
um,
an optical sorter if you've heard of that.
Yeah.
During one of our visits,
uh,
actually one of the most memorable things was somebody,
one of your employees was telling me about this and I was like blown away.
Like actually scans takes an x ray of each grade and you know,
for the grapes that aren't up to par like those them away.
And I was like,
no way.
You're kidding me.
No,
it is,
it's,
it's pretty amazing.
Yeah.
You basically choose which grapes that you think are the best and then you train
it to match those kinds of grapes and then exactly blows away with air.
The ones that don't match it and it's so much more precise than humans can be.
So it's actually made our wine making better in our wine quality better.
Um,
I mean I think we do other innovative and technologically advanced things in our
marketing department,
which I mom can speak to better.
But that's what we do at the winery in production.
Yeah.
And I also have to say,
you guys have an amazing website.
It's really good.
Just like,
yeah,
I think you guys should check it out.
Yeah,
thank you very much.
Yeah.
The buying flows,
purchasing all that,
the colonial animations.
Um,
yeah,
it's really good job there.
Well,
Hall wines.com or what?
Weinstock helpline.
Thank you Daniel.
So another question for you,
Jennifer.
So you have three sites now are the fruits,
St Elena,
Walt,
they all have their own special character and you unique news.
Could you,
for those of us that might not get the chance to visit,
could you tell us something special about each?
Sure.
So you know,
they are all different,
but each one of them carries I think sort of a,
which is they all have really great wine and they all have,
um,
an art collection woven throughout the property.
Our families really interested in art in lots of forms.
And then,
um,
they also reflect the neighborhood that they're in.
So our brother for property is up on the hill.
Have you been to the rather than property?
Okay.
Yeah,
so it's a very special small property.
It's built right by our family's home on the hillside and it has these caves
that are,
um,
that were built with Austrian Hartsburg dynasty bricks.
And then at the end of the cave,
as you know,
there's the chandelier room,
which has this beautiful piece of art that's a chandelier that looks like,
um,
sort of the roots of a tree with a Swarovski crystals that are lit up.
It's quite magnificent if you get to see it in person and we'd love for you all
to come visit.
But we do tastings underneath the chandelier and we also do private events.
I got married a few months ago and my rehearsal dinner was there.
It's just a really special intimate feel and it has more of an old world feel.
And then on the flip side,
I'd say our Saint Helena property has more of a new world feel.
So it's big modern.
We say that we have something there for everyone,
whether you want to come with your dog and taste wine outside or just get bottle
service,
we actually don't make anyone have to sit through a tasting.
If you think that's boring,
you can just order a bottle and you don't even have to listen to what we have to
say about it.
Although we would talk your ear off if you want us to.
Uh,
and we have beautiful art throughout that property as well.
And then our third property is Walt,
which is on the Sonoma Plaza and it's totally different.
It,
it,
um,
we'd like to say that it has the warmth of the home,
but the sophistication of an art gallery.
So you've very much feel at home.
It's very cozy,
charming,
more in tune with Sonoma properties,
but very beautiful.
And um,
uh,
you know,
we have wonderful wine educators and every property to.
Yep.
Uh,
so throughout your book,
you,
and we kind of touched on this earlier,
you talked about the numerous challenges you've faced in building hall.
For example,
early on,
losing the,
uh,
2000 plus cases in the fire.
And that was in your early days.
All right.
Um,
and then the difficulty is in like fat financing the operation during the Oh
eight oh nine economic crisis and then 2010 was interesting,
which was at the,
I believe it's a tough year for the industry as a whole in terms of the weather
conditions,
but you guys somehow we're able to turn out a hundred point wine,
um,
you know,
out of what you grew that year.
So you know,
you've seen that have a history of taking these like adverse situations and
navigating them through tier your advantage and kind of flipping them on their
side.
So,
um,
how have some of these losses and struggles shaped what call is today?
I'll give you an example of,
um,
the crop do you mentioned 2010,
but,
so 2011 was also very,
uh,
it was a difficult year and it was,
um,
I mean it looks sort of mediocre.
And then when we got down to harvest,
we thought our grapes weren't ripe enough,
so we kept him on the vine.
That's part of the risk thing.
We kept him on a little longer.
Uh,
and while they were hanging out there,
there was a torrential rain.
And so,
which was disaster.
And so the vines developed rot and,
and then the question is how do you sort out the bad berries from the good
berries?
Right?
So as in general,
the people who took the risk,
uh,
what happened to the 2011 in general was winds either tended to be too green and
we're scored very low and we're enjoyed that much by the public.
Or they stayed on too long and they were,
had a lot of rot and they weren't great.
And so our team figured out,
and this is,
comes back to that sort of,
you know,
deal with it,
figure it out,
think about it,
take a chance,
you know?
And so,
uh,
they figured out that if you,
that the rock was really at the stem where the stem attaches the berry to the,
to the right,
right,
right.
In that little juncture between the stem and the various,
so they figured out if they could shake the vine,
the bay,
not too hard,
but the bad vine,
the bad grapes would fall off.
And the good ones,
good grips and stay.
So we went around the truly every vineyard and we show everybody and um,
and we ended up with some really nice wines and got some great scores that year
in 2011 and I was like,
okay.
Yeah,
I mean 10 we did well too,
but I mean 11 in a way it was neater because we,
uh,
it was a very high risk,
you know?
Yeah.
But you just,
I think if you live and work in a climate where you,
uh,
the idea is just figure it out,
you know,
think about it.
I mean,
give it some thought and by the way,
you make a mistake,
it's okay.
Your job's not going anywhere.
You know,
you just try it.
And so I think our team,
they did a fabulous job that year and we ended up with some pretty cool,
pretty cool wines.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Yes,
I can attest to that.
Um,
so you don't have to potentially three,
a 100 point wines,
the 20,
2010 excellence,
the 2013 a reign in and then fingers crossed the 2013 Catherine Hall,
which pouring here today.
Um,
and all that has been in a,
in a span of about like two years or so.
Um,
so does it get easier or is the bar kind of raised every time?
Yeah,
well it doesn't get easier for sure.
And I shall we talk about that in the book?
You don't because,
um,
you,
when we first got,
I remember when we got our first score over 90 and it was 92 for one of our,
um,
cabernets some several years ago and it was like,
oh my,
it was amazing.
I mean,
we just,
nobody could stop talking about it was so exciting.
And now,
I mean,
like,
I think everyone reporting today has got scores in the 90s somewhere,
you know,
but,
and,
and I don't mean to demean that.
I mean,
we're really excited to have him,
but it's not the same as it was when we got a 92 the first time.
Yeah.
And so I guess in that sense the bar does sort of go higher.
Bye.
But I think at the same time,
you,
you don't,
if you ever set out to make a wine with the idea,
I'm going to get a great score on this wine,
then you are dead.
Because yeah,
I mean,
a great wine has to be authentic.
And so you've got to think about what does that vineyard want to be?
What's this vintage like?
I mean,
uh,
you don't want to manipulate a grade.
I mean,
I did manipulate a wine.
I think the great wines of the valley are not manipulated.
Do you know they are.
Um,
we have a wine maker here who I'm looking at right now,
but she just,
I mean,
great wines,
uh,
they have a sense of who they are.
Just like,
you know,
great people.
You know what I mean?
There's this feeling of honesty,
I think that goes around with any wine.
So you just have to sort of,
you seek out that truth and then you try to support it.
Awesome.
So you're,
the guiding principle is never a hundred point wine.
No.
Hey,
we do love it.
Yeah.
And it,
you know,
and then the other thing that happens and you start getting these,
when you start getting these wonderful scores,
then more people want you to make wine from that vineyard.
So it's this beautiful spiral because now we have wonderful vineyard owners who
are coming to us,
um,
who's,
who,
uh,
are,
would you like to have my grapes,
you know,
because they have a lot of pride in what they do too.
So they don't want to give,
have put a lot of pride into the wines that they grow grapes,
they grow and have it made into sort of a crummy wine.
So I mean,
we're really proud of excellence.
Comes from vineyard in our backyard,
um,
and rain and comes from one of our partners and they are as excited as we are
about it.
Jennifer,
back to you.
So all has a strong commitment to being green.
You farm organically.
You were the first winery in California.
It's a good gold Leed,
Leed gold.
Uh,
so why is this important to all and how has it impacted the wine you produce?
Well,
I think that for family business,
which we are,
it often is a reflection of your family's principles.
And one of our principals has always been our commitment to the environment.
Um,
we're all very environmentally focused in our family.
my mom drives electric vehicle,
my brother drives an electric vehicle.
I would like to drive an electric vehicle.
Um,
we actually have two electric vehicle parking spots at the winery.
So if you drive a Tesla or any other time,
oh,
do you?
Yeah,
my husband works for an environmental energy company.
I think it's just a big part of our life.
So we've been able to make that principle be part of the winery itself.
So yeah,
we're very proud of the gold lead certification,
especially paving the way for wineries.
And organic farming is really important to us.
The thing about organic farming is it,
it,
um,
it's not so much that changes the line really,
but it,
it takes longer to do organic farming.
And I think when you spend longer on,
on something,
not everything,
but in farming in particular,
in winemaking,
it just makes the quality better.
So they just have a higher attention to detail.
It's much more high touch.
And um,
it's,
it's been nice because we didn't set out from a marketing perspective to be
green.
That's just who we are.
And we've gotten a lot of recognition for that,
which we've been really proud of.
Right.
Yeah.
You feel like that's something you,
you ever sacrifice to like reduce costs or is that just kind of a core
part of what all is?
No,
we really feel like that's a core principle,
you know,
and we've been lucky that,
um,
we've been able to keep doing that.
So Catherine,
uh,
I'd love to your chapter,
our friends can only buy so much and I think this one probably resonates with a
lot of us here and in the audience.
Um,
so you talked about having to rely on,
let me get in your circle of friends and family.
Um,
and it's a struggle that we've all had it think are many of us at least.
I've definitely had this struggle myself.
Um,
or maybe when launching products at Google.
so what was the hardest part about scaling from friends and family?
And going from like a couple thousand cases a year at a couple of thousand cases
a month.
Yeah.
Well I think the first thing about,
um,
making any product is a,
and it's got to be good.
It's gotta be relevant.
It's got to be desirable.
It has to be intrinsically good and valuable.
And I think when you go to build it,
uh,
you have,
you want to focus on,
uh,
building the brand,
not building the sales numbers mean I'm speaking from us anyway.
Now our industry,
I mean,
I think the idea is that when you have a brand,
um,
that's your competitive edge.
I mean,
nobody else can be you.
Nobody else can be your product.
And so that means you gotta you gotta know your product,
you got to know who you are.
And then,
um,
and then I think you have to really,
you want to,
you have to communicate directly about who you are.
I mean,
when you think about the products that I think about when I go to buy my cold
press,
carrot juice,
I are,
we are,
you know,
um,
I like knowing that there's a person behind that product that is really the
cares about health.
You know?
Um,
when I buy products,
I like knowing that those people care about the environment.
Um,
I think there is increasingly this desire to shop with people who share your
values.
And so that means that you,
you want to communicate,
you are,
um,
and that's part of what your brand is.
I mean,
your brand is you.
So it's like,
this is who I am,
you know,
like it or don't like it,
you know?
But if you like it,
this is me.
And so you just sort of,
and then I think that it helps you scale on it.
But is it hard?
Uh,
I'll tell you in my business too,
when you start to scale,
you've got to be prepared because,
uh,
at first we were going to be a 7,500 7,500 case winery.
Now we're going to,
we're pushing towards 100,000 cases,
uh,
four months of the year.
I'm on American Airlines,
you know,
I mean,
it changes your life,
so you gotta be prepared to,
uh,
to make those changes and to jump when you have the opportunity.
I mean,
hesitate.
It did.
I think also in terms of scaling,
what's been really helpful is just hiring amazing people.
Oh,
hello?
Yeah,
that's the thing is,
yeah,
you can't,
you can't scale without a team.
I mean,
you can't build a business without a team.
It's gotta be,
we have just been so lucky with our team.
I mean,
we've hired,
our first employee was this,
we talk about this in the book to this wonderful guy named Mike Reynolds,
who is,
was our first wine maker now is our president.
And he just,
the three of us have just been,
he,
Craig and I,
um,
I mean Jeff was coming in now,
but I mean,
you know,
feel bit for many years it was,
uh,
it was,
it was the three of us,
you know,
and so,
uh,
we sort of,
we have,
we share values and Mike,
to this day,
anybody who's hired,
and I mean if you are working in the seller,
you're working in the hospitality or you're working in,
in any part of our operation,
Mike interviews all of our employees to know that we are all sort of,
um,
simpatico.
Yeah,
that's interesting.
I mean,
we've all been through the interview process here,
so I think we kinda can attest to that.
Um,
yeah,
it's,
it's not easy sometimes.
Uh,
so your whole brand has received more than 261 scores of 90 points or above.
That's a lot.
Congratulate,
but who's counting?
Yeah.
And then your wallet brand,
which is much smaller,
uh,
61 scores of,
of 90 points or above,
um,
you basically went from zero to a hundred in less than 15 years.
Uh,
what are the next 10 years look like for you guys?
Ah,
well,
hopefully they are full of lots of great wine and more consumers.
I think this whole,
our,
our industry is,
is going to change a whole lot.
I mean,
in sort of,
uh,
we put a lot of attention into hospitality.
So when you tell your story that you came up and you turn it happened to turn in
and you know,
got to know our wines and then join the club,
that's the perfect story.
That's what we hope to have happen.
And you know,
you only have your chance a chance to introduce yourself one time to somebody,
right?
Um,
but there is a whole world out there that will or won't have the chance to drive
up highway 29 and do that.
So we have to communicate with them directly in other ways.
So we put a lot of attention and we have from the,
really,
from the beginning into how do we market,
how do we communicate virtually,
you know,
how do we use social media,
which is nothing.
I mean,
everybody in the whole world is using social media.
But I continue.
It's not that common in our industry.
Yeah.
We sort of behind it.
So we,
we pay a lot of attention to how we communicate.
Uh,
we will do that and we will do it and we'll continue to work through our website
to try to enhance that relationship,
I think to,
um,
how we,
I,
I think if I were a distributor and that,
and these are the sort of middlemen,
there are several sort of middle people along the way in this industry.
I'd be concerned about where the industry is taking me because,
uh,
people right now,
we've only scratched the surface in terms of how people are buying wine.
Um,
most people still buy their wine walking into a store and buying it or coming
into a winery.
But why wouldn't you buy wine online?
I mean you,
when you buy everything else online,
but wine is something that you,
you can't taste,
you can't smell,
you can't feel it.
There's nothing about it that's unusual.
It's all reputation and brand.
So I think the,
the next 10 years we will see a huge change in our industry.
And hopefully Hollin Walt would be,
it will be at the forefront to try to,
um,
communicate and deliver product,
uh,
in,
in changing ways.
And then one more thing I want to say on that is that we're creating new brands.
So we're,
we will create a Zinfandel Brown,
we have a peanut Anwar brand and we have a hall brand.
But if we can do a Zinfandel,
a high quality Zinfandel can be made at a much lower cost than a holocaust,
high quality cabernet or Pinot Noir.
And so then this gives us a chance to open up to another level.
I've consumer who wants a fine wine but can't spend or doesn't want to spend as
much money as they would on the other brands.
So I think new brands will also help us.
I think the idea of quality will be consistent,
but if we can get more people into our sort of family,
hopefully they'll been,
we'll go have a Zinfandel at peanut Anwar and a Cabernet,
you know?
Yeah.
It seems like there'd be a challenge though.
So for those of us that are familiar with your wines,
we know exactly what we want to buy online.
But like kind of the,
how do you address the,
uh,
the try before you buy for like new customers.
So no other things you've purchased online.
You can,
it arrive.
So you try it on,
you don't like it,
free returns,
all that stuff.
Try something different,
get your money back whenever.
How do you see that?
Well,
right now we have a policy.
If something is wrong with the bottle,
you can send it back to us or we'll pick it up or you just let us know,
we'll credit your account.
So,
um,
that's true.
If a bottle is corked or there's something wrong.
Now if you just simply don't like it,
um,
you know,
honestly if someone really didn't,
like,
if someone didn't like it,
not really.
Didn't like if someone didn't like it,
we would make it up to them.
I mean,
I mean the most important thing is,
is our customer relationship.
But have we figured out how to do that online?
No,
I'd sure maybe we need some Googlers to help.
That's know 20% project.
Yeah.
So last Saturday at a Saint Helena winery,
you hosted harvest towns and event where a proceeds benefit the Napa humane
society.
Um,
so what are some other charitable events that the winery participates in
throughout the valley or out the winery itself?
Sure.
We really love participating in these and hosting these charity events.
Harvest hands is a super fun event where everyone brings their dog or one of my
friends brought their cat,
their cat ones.
You can bring any pet that you want.
And then we have sort of like fun things like pet massages and other stuff.
Um,
were your animals also chip installation?
I think as well.
Um,
and then you also get to taste,
taste,
wine and all benefits the charity.
But our biggest charity event that we have every year is called the Cabernet
cookoff.
It's in April,
I think this year.
It's on April 29th,
and it's a really fun event.
We've done it now for eight years.
We had 700 people come last year and it's on our great lawn.
And basically,
uh,
chefs from around bay area partner with a charity of their choice that's local.
And then they create a dish to pair with our Cabernet.
So this year there'll be,
there'll be creating a dish using some of our Napa cab 2013 and then there'll be
pairing it with the Napa cab 2013 and then we have a panel of judges who have
the most fun job ever.
I'm trying all the different food pairings and then the winning charity of the
winning team and then that charity,
then it gets them the majority of the proceeds of the event,
but then every charity that it participates also goes home with a check.
So we love that event.
It's become a huge hit in the valley.
And if anyone wants to come,
we'd love to have you.
It's a really great time.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
Um,
questions in the audience.
We have a Mike over here.
I was hoping you could talk a little bit more about the business aspect of the
winery in terms of it's well known that it's hard to make money in the wind wine
industry.
So I wanted to hear,
um,
from your perspective,
what it takes,
um,
to be financially successful or profitable as a winery.
And then maybe touch on how the economics of the winery you have changed as you
guys have,
um,
extended.
So I have to say that really hackneyed phrase that is used so often,
uh,
in the valley,
which is a,
that's the way you make a small fortune in Napa is you start with a large one.
But,
uh,
your question goes,
I think to the core of why a great wines will always be made by family owned
wineries because
okay,
we have to be,
well in our case we have to be profitable,
but we don't have to report to a board of directors or to,
uh,
people who are looking at a 12 year return.
We can look at a return on an investment that's 10 years out.
And,
um,
because,
and I think if you are building,
uh,
a great winery,
which is we're trying to do is you've got to look long range.
I mean they just,
um,
there is so much,
it's so capital intensive to from the
well,
from the tanks that you ferment in the,
uh,
the oak barrels that you use.
I mean,
you did,
we,
we committed from the outset that we were going to not cut corners when we were
making our wines.
And so,
no,
I guess in the sense,
once you make that commitment then it sort of becomes easy because you just say,
okay,
we're going for it.
You have to be patient,
you have to,
the,
you have to look longterm.
Uh,
so we are,
um,
we're cashflowing it's been awhile,
you know,
I mean,
and we started in,
it started in the business 20 years ago.
I had no idea how you sold,
why I'm in a lot of that is what we talk about in the book,
you know,
I mean,
we just,
um,
I mean I knew my dad was a grower,
so I knew a bit about growing grapes.
I knew a little bit about making wine and I knew zero about how you sell a wine.
And,
I mean,
I didn't know who made the wine making the wine buying decisions in the story
even.
I mean,
that's how far we had to go.
So in 20 years we made a lot of the mistakes,
but,
uh,
but it was a long term venture.
And so that's,
so,
uh,
I think what I would do if I were looking and my guess is there are people in
this room and who are watching this who are,
might think that they might want to get in our business.
Right?
And I,
I think the first thing is to just know how much time do you want to put into
it?
Because as I said,
it's a big jump.
You make a couple hundred cases,
that's one thing.
You make a thousand cases.
Nobody has that many friends.
And uh,
so,
uh,
but if you start,
say for example,
as a grower,
when 95% of the wine is in the vineyard anyway,
so then you're,
you're really involved and what's the core of what this whole industry is about?
And then I think that's a great way to see if you enjoy the,
the lifestyle.
I mean you've got,
if you don't like the lifestyle,
you don't want to be in this business,
you can make so much more money someplace else for the time and effort that she
put into it.
But it,
if you do,
then it's just everything cause it's art,
it's business,
it's just a,
it's dynamic.
It encompasses your world here at Google more hopefully in the future.
Um,
and,
and it's farming too,
so it puts you in touch with what's real in life,
the seasons of life,
you know,
the,
the sort of,
the humility of dealing year after year with Mother Nature.
I mean,
there is everything wonderful about this business,
but if you don't for me,
but if you don't love it,
if you don't want to be in it.
In your book,
you mentioned that you were investing in some cool new technologies to make your
wines even better.
Could you give us a hint on what some of those might be?
I think Jen,
you mentioned the,
uh,
did you hear me mention the optical sorter earlier?
Yes.
Super Cool.
Okay.
And that's really,
that's a key.
That really is key.
You know,
I mean that's just,
that's,
that's really been,
I think,
uh,
a huge step forward in terms of quantity and quality.
I think the tanks now that,
I mean the tanks that we use in Saint Helena are much better to work with then
the tanks that we have up in our first facility,
which was in Rutherford.
I mean,
that's how the technology has changed and what it's about.
It's about precision.
And we can really control temperature better than we ever could in temperature
is such a key factor in wine making.
And uh,
we can control it.
We can toggle it,
we can just zero down.
So it's just this sort of an added degree of precision.
Craig,
my husband and I were over at Uc Davis about,
I dunno,
eight months ago and looking about,
it's sort of this,
uh,
systems where we'll be able to monitor someday.
Hopefully not.
I bet you not.
Everything seems to be exponentially happening.
So it won't be that long.
Uh,
is,
um,
be able to monitor us vine by vine,
you know,
uh,
from,
from a desk away from the vineyard where we can look at,
you know,
uh,
sort of the water of that soil,
those that's getting on that particular vine.
I mean that's going to give us a lot more control in the vineyard where as I
said before is just such a key part of it.
And then the,
um,
technology about how we communicate is huge.
And so there it is.
I mean I,
I think on a,
just on communicating,
it's just,
uh,
being open,
having great,
having a great team.
I mean we are so lucky to have the team that we've got,
um,
cause most,
the head of our marketing operation for example,
is she,
she worked in digital and in digital advertising for a while.
But uh,
but she said that she was never even thinking about working for a winery.
She loves wine and her husband is in our business.
Um,
he's a,
he's a som,
lives up in the Napa valley,
but she never thought about working for a winery because she didn't think
anybody.
So it was into that,
you know,
and so then it was totally a wonderful marriage,
is continuous.
But then she is brought in more and more people who love wine and who love
working in that world.
So I think that that world,
which is really your world I think is going to continue to grow and the are
breathtaking.
The exciting.
Thank you.
It kind of goes to Melissa's question earlier.
One of the keys for our success in terms of getting in the black from when we
were in the red for a really long time was developing innovative marketing
strategies.
So even though it seems totally commonplace,
a lot of the practices that we do with our ecommerce platform are very one of a
kind in the wine business.
Pretty much no one else does.
I think we have one of the top individual wine online sales a bit,
um,
any individual winery.
So we just have a great team that,
um,
obviously our scores have helped tremendously and that's a big part of being a
profitable winery.
But having,
using great technology and marketing strategies has been super helpful.
And which Google is a big part.
Yes.
Thank you.
Btw Yeah.
Could you elaborate on the importance of professional reviews and ratings on
daily decisions of a wine maker and is a perfect score,
your ultimate end goal and what are the things you're unwilling to compromise on
to achieve a higher step?
Love the,
I'm going to take that.
Yeah,
you can do it,
but I love that question.
No,
you can't.
Yeah.
Do a wine.
Um,
you can't make decisions based on what a score is going to be.
I mean,
you just,
uh,
you lose your authenticity.
You just,
uh,
it's got,
you gotta be thinking,
uh,
all about that wine and uh,
and that,
that vineyard,
what that grape can do,
where it's going to go.
Um,
you start thinking about a score.
I,
you just,
uh,
you've lost it.
You just moved into a sort of,
uh,
this area of,
um,
mediocrity,
which hopefully we will never move to.
So,
uh,
so we don't make decisions that way.
In the second question was,
I think it was sort of this part of the same question,
but anyway,
the answer is yes.
Got It.
How does it,
how does it impact the daily life of the winemaker?
I think,
yeah.
Well it doesn't,
with real estate being so high in the entire state and being in Napa where I'm
mean,
what's,
what's the square footage these days?
We don't know.
Right.
But you probably do,
but you see these wineries now opening in an old transmission shop and like
Oakland's or you know,
up in long poke,
we have a whole thing going on up there.
How was this guerrilla type winemaking affecting people in a place that is
traditional?
Like Napa is,
uh,
seems as if they're,
you know,
that you can buy grape juice or grapes,
I should say,
wherever you want and the state truck it to your facility and,
and make great wine.
Does it put you guys at a competitive disadvantage to be having everything in
Napa where the real estate prices are so high?
Okay.
I can take that.
Yeah,
I mean,
in general,
we don't consider other Nafa wineries to be our competitors.
And I would say in the bay area either with,
we really consider them to be our competitors.
We think of wines and other countries as being competitive to us.
And even then,
not so much because we're actually competing against people that are drinking
beer and other kinds of alcoholic beverages.
The more people consume wine,
the better it actually helps our winery.
So we're really happy to see gorilla winemaking operations popping up all over
and actually bringing that closer people in the city is great.
Um,
from our perspective,
yeah,
they're not competing with us directly.
I think the really just overall helping everyone.
Um,
and yeah,
a lot of people do just buy bulk wine or they'll buy the grapes and press them
themselves or they'll get them custom crush to somewhere else.
And I think,
you know,
good for them.
That's great.
It does nothing but help us.
Yeah,
totally agree.
I mean,
I think they just think about your own,
um,
wine drinking behavior.
I mean,
I think the more wine you have,
you,
you try,
the more wine you want to try.
I mean,
it just sort of,
you,
it just whets your appetite to know more about wine.
So I think we are all benefited by having more wines.
And in fact,
in our wallet brand,
a lot of our wines are grapes.
We do trucking.
I mean,
but we don't,
we don't buy the juice though.
I mean,
we are hugely involved in the farming.
You know,
when we first started out,
my dad was a farmer,
I was saying earlier.
Um,
so my thought at the beginning was we would own all of our own vineyards and we
would,
you know,
make the wines because we could control it.
And my husband also calls me a control freak,
you know?
I mean,
I just think we really,
but the fact is that there are so many wonderful vineyards out there that we
would never have acts were that grows grapes to which we would never have
access.
So we find that we are now,
uh,
particularly for wall,
but also for hall buying grapes from other,
uh,
grape vineyards.
And so the idea of Walt is,
uh,
we have one of the most famous vineyards in Oregon is Dick Shay's Vinu shape
shaping Anwar.
You all I'm seeing is not,
so this is such a good wine group.
And so,
uh,
we buy grapes from Dick and we,
you know,
and we'd pick him at night and you struck him down and,
and then we make the wine up.
I mean,
so if you're going to make really quality,
uh,
wine,
you have to,
it's very expensive to do,
but,
but we like it and,
and like,
luckily,
so that people who buy the wine,
so we do that too.
We don't buy the juice,
but we buy grapes from other vineyards that we will truck in.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
Good.
No,
it's true.
I mean,
I think people will come,
you'll have a different experience trying align on our property,
then you will in your own home.
I think your environment hugely affects your enjoyment of the line.
Um,
but yeah,
no,
I think there's people,
we'll try our wine for the first time in a restaurant in New York,
but then,
you know,
come out to the property and like it
from a different perspective,
you know,
um,
I want to say something on you used the word tradition,
which I,
uh,
which is so it's such a critical part of this industry.
Um,
so our,
one of our phrases,
we've got a bunch of internal phrases like have,
you know,
what was it something or die,
innovate or die.
Right.
Okay.
So,
um,
you know,
one of ours is,
um,
true where a tradition meets innovation.
And so,
uh,
we are in wine making is,
has fabulous traditions associated with,
and they are tried and true and they'd been around for many,
many,
many years.
But,
uh,
but,
but innovation allows us to refine on that.
So the idea,
I think of the winery in the future,
and this goes actually back to one of the questions that you were saying
earlier,
Daniel,
was,
uh,
or your comments was,
um,
what's the future for us?
And I think part of the future is to,
uh,
to take advantage of the innovation that technology has afford this and we'll
continue to afford us,
but not to lose the great parts about tradition.
Um,
so it's this really,
it's,
it's a lovely blend,
you know,
and,
uh,
I,
I would like to never be regarded as I've traditional winery,
you know,
I mean,
I,
but I hope we will always be a winery that respects and uses the best of
tradition.
What percentage of your wine is sold online and what percentage is sold at the
winery and club together?
That will help frame my next question,
but online,
very small presale smile.
Oh,
so small.
I mean,
we are watching it.
under 10% or 5%.
I mean,
it's really small,
but you know,
let's talk again in three years.
It's going to be huge.
Um,
but I mean,
but wine club,
um,
that's a very important part of who we are.
It's sort of this,
uh,
I'd say over,
um,
music.
I thought maybe it was,
oh,
I think it's more,
is it more than third?
Yeah.
I mean,
well for 60%,
um,
and growing of our sales are direct to consumer and most of that is wine club.
So it's a huge part of,
um,
wine club is a huge part of who we are.
You sound like smart marketers in the wine business,
that's for sure.
Like trying to lead the cutting edge as you start to grow into online consumers
where they don't have the chance to drive up 29 and swing into,
you know,
meet funny Fufu.
Um,
what do you wish you knew about your online consumer?
Oh,
oh yeah.
Well,
their email address.
Yeah.
Give me an email address.
I can do so much,
um,
before that,
before that.
Yeah.
So I mean,
we want to know everything we can,
you know what I mean?
That's,
uh,
we want to know where they live.
We want to know their buying pattern.
We want to know,
um,
you know,
give us their gender or when we can stereotype with the best of him,
give us,
give us as much information as we can get and we'll build a model around that
person.
I mean,
I,
uh,
we want to know their income.
We want to know,
um,
what kind of luxury products do they use me?
Now,
how do,
so how do we cope brand?
Um,
do they join other clubs?
Uh,
we know that there are people out there who,
uh,
love good wine,
but who are not wine club.
They don't want to join a wine club.
They don't want to have that tie.
So we created this program called online rewards.
So that's where,
and it's so if you want to shop online,
um,
and you don't want to be part of a club,
we got something for you.
So you can,
you buy and then you meet a threshold at six,
at $600 in a calendar year,
then you get 5% off.
If you are by a lot of wine,
if you're at $2,000 in a calendar year,
you get 10% off.
So,
I mean,
it's,
uh,
we're,
we're trying to figure out,
I mean,
it's,
so much of our world is about customization.
So the more and in this digital world allows us to do that.
So the more we can know about who they are,
you know,
I can't think of anything.
I wouldn't want to know.
Yeah.
Basically what they like so we can show them what they like.
Hi,
I'm,
you just mentioned about a cold branding and actually came to your winery.
First time I went through the Alexis Club.
Can you tell us more about like who you partner with,
how you select the partnership and how's that working for your wineries?
So the credit,
who else are we involved with?
It's sort of evolving.
I don't,
um,
we've done,
obviously with Lexis,
we'd done some luxury brands are really natural for us.
We've been doing,
we've done some,
uh,
we're doing some,
wedding things with Tiffany now.
Um,
we're trying to get more into the wedding market.
especially people with their last name hall.
They really like,
they really like partnering with using us for their wedding,
for their wedding line.
Yeah.
I thought we did something with American Express.
We have done things with American Express.
What do you like,
you know,
luxury brands that you can think of and,
um,
and we're,
you know,
we're always looking,
I mean we have,
that's part of,
we have a team that's sort of part of one of their responsibilities and we have
one guy whose job is to sort of look around and see who can we work with.
Yeah.
We'll obviously a Tesla.
We doing,
we have the,
you know,
I mean we have the test,
the state test,
the station I think you mentioned that is that we've been doing some things with
Tesla.
Would you mind introducing what we're calling today?
Um,
so I do this.
Sure,
sure.
Okay.
So,
well,
let me see.
I will start with what I was drinking.
That's a Sauvignon Blanc,
um,
that this is under the hall brand.
So Hall is the,
all the Bordeaux varietals.
So that would be a Sauvignon Blanc for the white.
And uh,
this is the only wine in our portfolio between hall and wealth.
The seasonal.
Okay.
Uh,
it is,
uh,
100% sob blog.
What I think is special about this is something that our team experimented with
and keen to.
Uh,
and that is that we leave this juice on the lees.
and so what,
you know,
I mean it's still video blog should be bright and have nice acid and have these
like,
I think Mellon qualities or grape grapefruit on the nose.
We expect that,
but when it's not great,
it's going to have,
it's sort of be a little green or it's going to be thin,
mid palate.
And so if you leave this on the leaves,
you can get this sort of lusciousness mid palate.
And I think they'd just done a beautiful job.
And obviously I like it because that's what I've worked for myself today.
Um,
to start with.
Uh,
then we,
the peanut auto is the gaps crowd.
I think we're pouring the gas crown.
Yeah.
So the gap's crown,
I is under the Walt Walt label.
This comes from,
uh,
over towards the coast in Sonoma.
It's a out wine that has sort of,
um,
oh,
uh,
sort of,
sort of Raspberry Jamey I think on the nose.
The sort of the pallet has a,
I would say some,
um,
sort of earthy mushroom quality to it.
Um,
it's got nice acid in it.
But what distinguishes I think in particularly this wine for us in our portfolio
is it's a very robust wine.
I mean it's a really sort of more angular I think in terms of its structure.
Its uh,
the,
uh,
it's growing climate is very severe in the census,
got very,
very strong winds,
uh,
in that area.
And so these are very,
very hardy grapes and,
uh,
and it's reflected in the wine is produced from them.
The uh,
two calves we have are the cur.
I get three caps.
Well you guys are great.
Okay.
So,
um,
in the Napkin Napa cab 2013,
uh,
is,
very sort of dark inky color,
uh,
is,
this is the wine we make the most of,
maybe the best value in the portfolio because that's our one that most people
get to know us through.
So we try to really load in wonderful fruit in and then hope people come back
and join the club and buy more wine.
And just do just what Daniel did.
And um,
and so it has this sort of chocolatey quality to it.
I think,
uh,
in the,
in the uh,
taste,
it's a aged
something under 20 months,
a bit,
I think about 18 months in French oak by the way.
But we only use French oak as part of,
we were talking really about cutting corners.
I mean I think we really looked at trying other oaks,
but there's just nothing for us that compares to French Oak.
There's that subtlety about it that just is wonderful.
So that's the,
so this is likewise age didn't um,
French oak.
So it's a,
we designed this wine to be drunk right now.
Robert Parker thinks is going to be fabulous in 20 years.
He says it's good now,
but he says he thinks it could go 20 years.
I think in 20 years is going to be hard to find a bottle of it.
I don't know.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
we occur with French for heart,
comes from the heart of the valley,
which is say Halina,
uh,
from are mostly from this our vineyard right by the Saint Iliana winery called
Berg felt.
So since this is a really warm part of Napa Valley,
warm climate is going to produce grapes that aren't as fruit forward,
although you will get some black fruit in here.
Uh,
it is,
um,
sort of,
more,
not as much food in,
a little more sort of Mocha quality at for me on that taste,
a big bigger wine.
And then finally the Catherine Hall,
which to begin with has a very nice name,
uh,
is uh,
comes in part from our,
the vineyard where our houses are family houses and it is a,
um,
it's a wonderful wine.
Uh,
not to go back to scores,
but I just have to say,
so,
uh,
Parker pre rated this a in barrel at 98 to 100.
So this could end,
that really could be our third hundred point wine.
But anyway,
it is what it is and I think it's beautiful.
Here's the,
you will try it today.
And,
um,
those of you who are seeing,
seeing is later.
Sorry,
you just have to come,
come to the winery and try it.
Um,
but it is a,
uh,
it's a very big wine.
It's very dense.
It's got lots of dark fruit in it.
It's a,
uh,
it's huge.
It's got,
now it's very young at 2013.
So it's got this sort of 80 fat that makes it very appealing and you just do,
it's luscious.
But,
uh,
the challenge is going to be to wait cause it really is going to be better in
four or five or longer years.
But it is drinking so beautifully now that it's very tempting.
Well,
thank you so much.
Oh,
thank you.
You guys made
[inaudible].